après 20 mois de guerre civile les
premiers réfugiés libanais regagnent
leur pays
six mois après le raid surprise le
cinéma s'empare de l'opération en tb en
réponse au ps les communistes
continuerons à appliquer l'accord
d'union commente enrayer la violence sur
les stades le point de vue de paul
lefeuvre
les compagnies aériennes régionales en
déficit c'est le dossier de ce journal
la meuse et messieurs bonsoir toute
cette actualité ce sommaire mais d'abord
c'est l'information qui vient de nous
parvenir
mini remaniement gouvernemental à paris
qui vient d'être annoncée à l'elysée par
raymond barre monsieur claude couler
député républicain indépendant de
lorraine entre dans l'équipe du premier
ministre en tant que secrétaire d'état
auprès de monsieur michel d'ornano forcé
j'ai proposé au président de la
république la nomination d'un secrétaire
d'état au ministère de l'industrie et de
la recherche en raison des problèmes
importants que ce ministère aura traité
dans les prochains mois
quand importants dossiers industriels
le problème de l'énergie en partie voilà
pour la raison officielle il y en
ad'autres voilà une décision en rapport
direct avec les municipales double
rapport même d'abord il faut bien voir
que ce n'est pas par hasard que michel
d'ornano qui depuis deux ans et demi se
passe est socata d'état en allemand d un
jeune norman ou se présente aux
municipales à paris il a besoin de
quelqu'un pour le décharger son travail
à l'industrie c'est donc bien la preuve
qu'il est résolu à aller jusqu'au bout
dans la bataille de paris
quels que soient les obstacles par
exemple du rpr la deuxième raison nous
déplace de 300 km là non plus ce n'est
un secret pour personne
claude couler sera candidat à la mairie
de nancy une mairie dont le titulaire
actuel
marcel martin est secoué par un scandale
qui l'oppose au préfet de lorraine
malgré cela il semblait vouloir se
représenter notre couler avait donc
besoin d'un petit coup de pouce des
giscardiens voilà qui est fait
il est aujourd'hui ce qu'elle a dit
voilà donc pour l'actualité à chaud et
la dernière nouvelle qui nous étaient
parvenues juste avant le début de ce
journal il y a quelques semaines encore
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'à
l'observateur qu'est l'homme politique
que les libanais aurait un noël à noël
bien à eux un noël à peu près normale en
tout cas on le souhaite c'est
aujourd'hui la réalité chaque jour tous
les avions qui se posent à beyrouth
ramène au pays des centaines de libanais
exilé volontairement depuis 20 mois
depuis que le canon le sang et les
larmes ont remplacé le sourire et la
douceur de vivre du liban éternel
aujourd'hui où l'on est encore loin
malgré tout d'une véritable
normalisation
l'espoir renaît peu à peu avec ces
hommes et ces femmes qui reviennent
plein de confiance dans leur propre
avenir et dans celui de leur pays depuis
que la paix syrienne s'est installé à
beyrouth les libanais rentrer chez eux
al'approche des fêtes de noël plus d'un
millier débarquent chaque jour à
l'aéroport de beyrouth
les places pour le liban se réserve
trois semaines à l'avancé et les avions
sont surchargés ces libanais qui
reviennent après plus d'un an d'exil
appartiennent surtout à des familles
aisées qui s'était installée à paris ou
à londres pendant la guerre civile
bondam depuis combien de temps vous
n'étiez pas venu au liban des faits à
nancy - rapide près c'est à dire au
début de la guerre oui c'est exactement
ça et maintenant vous revenez vous est à
dire dans votre pays
oui c'est mon propre pays quoi vous avez
confiance matin c'est pas la confiance
qui compte c'est le seul chiffre c'est
l'amour c'est quelque chose qui nous
attachent à ces pays là et vous avez eu
des nouvelles de votre maison pendant
que vous étiez à paris et non ils m'ont
ils ont réclamé sont réquisitionnés
votre maison oui il ya des choix qui me
remplacer et qu'est ce que vous allez
faire alors
maintenant j en sais rien absolument
rien dur est venu pour me reconstruire
comme le pire des étudiants à
l'université de bordeaux en premier de
médecine
je viens au liban pour voir un parent
pour les provinces et les vacances de
noël et vous voici la situation sur le
calme beauce était si calme fixe stats
registre ici j'espère que maintenant que
tout va bien
vous rentrez définitif terme aux yeux un
atterrissage à beyrouth
vous rentrez définitivement ce fut la
guerre on bouge plus et votre maison n'a
pas été bombardé pendant ces événements
ma maison a été complètement fichue
ainsi que l'hôtel où nous étions alors
on n'a plus rien mais on revient après
un mois de p 500 milles libanais sont
déjà rentrés dans leur pays mais trois
cent mille autres se tournent encore
dispersés dans le monde
après un mois de guerre si le retour des
libanais est un signe qui ne trompe pas
la guerre du liban et bien fini mais
pour les chrétiens les musulmans ou les
palestiniens et là le goût amer d'une
paix imposée par les 30000 soldats
syriens installés au liban
il vous contrôler tous les 500 mètres
empêche les combattants de se promener
en armes et occupe même aujourd'hui tous
les grands journaux libanais la guerre
civile pourra difficilement reprendre
mais on peut prévoir des actions de
résistance contre les syriens
ça n'est pas encore la grande paix au
liban on pense à beyrouth qu'elle ne
viendra qu'avec un règlement globe
bal du conflit du moyen-orient pendant
ce temps est toujours sur les rives de
la méditerranée israël vit une nouvelle
crise politique le premier ministre
isaac rabin a exclu de son gouvernement
trois ministres du parti religieux qui
n'avait pas apprécié une petite fête
organisée sur l'aéroport de lod le jour
du sabbat pour accueillir des chasseurs
américains
en fait il s'agit d'un prétexte d'une
manoeuvre politique très habile du
premier ministre qui en mettant son
gouvernement en minorité et en
s'apprêtant à dissoudre l'assemblée va
se trouver les mains libres pour entamer
des négociations avec les arabes et l'ol
paie comme il le souhaitait ce sont
trois de ces appareils des f 15
américains qui sont à l'origine de la
crise gouvernementale
le 10 décembre dernier le gouvernement
tout entier se rend à l'aéroport de tel
aviv pour recevoir officiellement les
trois premiers et f15 d'une commande de
25 de ses chasseurs bombardiers
américains
c'est un vendredi des ministres du parti
religieux accusent le chef du
gouvernement d'avoir violé le shabbat
réponse du premier ministre rabin la
cérémonie s'est terminée 15 minutes
avant le coucher du soleil
itzhak rabin qui profite pourtant de
cette occasion pour obliger les
ministres religieux a démissionné se
retrouvait donc en minorité au parlement
et provoquer ainsi des élections
anticipées sans doute pour le printemps
prochain
une manoeuvre qui d'ici là permettra au
gouvernement rabin chargé d'expédier les
affaires courantes et qui n'aura de
compte à rendre à personne d'avoir les
mains libres pour engager des
négociations avec les pays arabes est
précisément du côté arabe chacun semble
vouloir s'orienter vers une rapide
reprise de la conférence de genève le
chef d'état syrien en visite officielle
au caire annonce qu'il serait tout à
fait d'accord pour que de l'autre côté
de la table de négociation face à israël
plon constitue une délégation arabe
unique comprenant syriens et égyptiens
aujourd'hui réconciliée
les jordaniens avec l'accord du roi
hussein et l'ol paie organisation de
libération de la palestine qui n'est
plus aujourd'hui
après les évènements du
liban en mesure de refuser une ouverture
de négociations si tous les autres
partenaires dont aujourd'hui d'accord
vous souvenez certainement de
l'incroyable odyssée des parachutistes
israéliens le 2 juillet 1976 sur
l'aéroport d'entebbe et kampala je vous
rappelle en deux mots l'histoire le 27
juin un airbus d'air france est
détournée par des palestiniens entre tel
aviv et paris idi amin dada le président
de l'ouganda accepte d'accueillir
l'appareil et ses passagers tout en
garantissant la vie des otages en
assurant leur protection leur sécurité
amin dada ne cache pas sa sympathie pour
les palestiniens
quatre jours plus tard tout juste après
minuit des avions militaires israéliens
parviennent à se poser sur l'aéroport de
vendée kampala après une courte bagarre
et dans un effet de surprise tout à fait
total les gardiens sont désarmés les
palestiniens battu tout cela en quelques
minutes et les otages embarque pour
nairobi est à la vie depuis
les journalistes des romanciers ont
raconté chacun à leur manière le disent
et israéliennes cette semaine et bien
c'est un film à grand spectacle avec une
distribution éblouissante qui à son tour
fait revivre toute l'opération d'un bébé
en tb une aventure hors du commun
les médias en ont fait des semaines
durant leur cheval de bataille
l'extraordinaire aventure des 103 otage
de l'airbus délivrés par des commandos
israéliens à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de tel aviv est immédiatement
été récupéré par l'édition et parle
cinéma
le raid israélien pourtant fait des
victimes trois des otages un membre du
commando venu d'israël et 20 soldats
ougandais ce tribut c'était le plus
mince que tel-aviv pouvait envisager
zéro heure une minute le vendredi 2
juillet trois avions hercules se posa en
tb
vingt minutes plus tard les otages sont
libérés l'avion d'air france est
détourné le dimanche 27 juin dès le
mardi les israéliens envisagent une
solution militaire personne ne s'est
jamais douté de rouge et personne n'a
rien su à quel point je peux vous le
dire que des agents secrets en israël
américain qui pourtant sont le sait sont
régalés qui savent beaucoup de choses
bien effectivement eux avaient appris
seulement vendredi quelque chose
ils ont vu qu'on avait des places et des
avions qu'on avait repeint certains
avions
ils ont informé washington en disant
nous avons l'impression que les
israëliens préparer quelque chose et à
washington
il ya eu la mise interprétation d'un mal
interpréter le fait on a dit non non ce
n'est pas possible
israël va à l'opération
de manger ils ont rompu silence radio
les socialistes ont beaucoup travaillé
sur le dossier des municipales pendant
ce week-end sans pouvoir régler
toutefois tous les litiges et apaiser
tous les conflits les socialistes comme
les communistes voudrais pas revenir aux
termes de leur accord national pour
toutes les villes de plus de 30 mille
habitants à présenter des listes d'union
de la gauche par tous or si cela était
possible jusqu'à présent dans plus de la
moitié des cas il reste encore pas mal
de problèmes à régler à tel point que le
ton semble avoir quelque peu monté d'un
cran pendant ce week-end entre le ps et
le pc à propos de paris en particulier
et de toutes les villes où les amis de
françois mitterrand ont l'impression
tout quel disque les prétentions
communistes sont exorbitantes
avant d'en venir à la réponse des
communistes je vous propose de faire le
point sur ces négociations pc ps à
propos de l'accord du 28 juin prévoit
que dans toutes les villes la gauche se
présentera unie aux municipales des
négociations sont ouvertes pour
l'établissement des listes surtout dans
les deux cents dix neuf villes de plus
de 30 mille habitants où les listes sont
bloqués un accord est déjà intervenue
dans plus de la moitié des grandes
villes mais dans d'autres les
négociations butent soit sur la
répartition au sein des listes soit sur
les têtes de liste c'est le cas par
exemple à laval et à aix en provence où
le parti socialiste se présentera seul
ce qui exclut toute municipalité d'union
de la gauche
marseille est une exception car la ville
est divisée en secteurs et là une
municipalité d'une la gauche peut être
constitué même si le pc et le ps au
présentent séparément
hier la convention du parti socialiste a
donc décidé de constituer des listes
homogène là où un accord n'aura pu être
trouvé on a dit que c'est une façon de
mettre le parti communiste au pied du
mur
réponse des communistes nous estimons
que la convention nationale du parti
socialiste doit amener un certain nombre
de motifs d'inquiétude pour ceux qui
veulent l'union je dirais qu en ce qui
nous concerne les communistes après
cette convention nous allons continuer
comme nous n'avons cessé de le faire a
proposé l'union et y comprise nous
sommes persuadés que les travailleurs et
bien nous aiderons pour que l'accord
national soit appliquée partout
vous parlez de paris dans la capitale la
préparation des élections municipales au
sein de la gauche provoque un sérieux
conflit le torchon brûle depuis
l'annnonce de la candidature du
socialiste georges sarre entre les
socialistes et les communistes ce soir
dans un communiqué la fédération
parisienne du parti communiste sur
bancaire pour que nous ayons et se
demande si la fédération socialiste
n'aurait pas décidé de renoncer à
constituer des listes communes et de
défaire ainsi l'union existant dans la
capitale depuis 1965
monsieur black le ministre du travail
est revenu ce matin au cours d'une
conférence de presse sur le problème de
la politique contractuelle elle continue
a dit le ministre mais elle doit tenir
compte de la situation du pays raisonner
en 1976 comme en 1974
c'est ignorer que le monde a changé
c'est vivre dit le ministre sa petite
vie et oublier que nous sommes dans un
monde solidaire et toujours pour
christian bilhac les contrats salariaux
sont une politique de dialogue et non
une politique d'automaticité la session
parlementaire d'automne a pris fin ce
soir elle a été consacré pour
l'essentiel tant à l'assemblée nationale
qu'au sénat à la discussion budgétaire
tout simplement retenu des ces derniers
débats une petite phrase de raymond
barre cet après-midi devant les
sénateurs j'ai été personnellement
sensibles a dit le premier ministre au
soutien que vous avez bien voulu ma
portée aussi bien par l'appui que vous
avez donnée au progrès au projet du
gouvernement que par les critiques qui
si elles ont été parfois radicales ont
toujours été formulées sur le temps
d'une courtoisie qui dans les temps que
nous vivons est assez rare commentaire
également sur la session qui vient de
s'écouler de robert ballanger le
président du groupe communiste à
l'assemblée pour lui le marathon
budgétaire n'aura pas permis au
parlement de jouer pleinement son rôle
et monsieur ballanger de dénoncé la
désinvolture et le mépris du pouvoir à
l'égard du parlement
alors que les propriétaires commencent à
réclamer les augmentations de loyers
pour l'année 77 vous devez savoir que
cette augmentation est plafonnée pour
les locaux d'habitation
elle ne peut dépasser 6 ennemis % du
loyer qui était payé le 15 septembre
dernier le propriétaire ne peut en aucun
cas prendre prétexte du gel des loyers
après cette date pour exiger une
augmentation supplémentaire
seule exception à cette règle les loyers
régie par la loi de 1948
quatre personnes ont été blessées ce
matin à paris dans le 9ème
arrondissement au cours d'une fusillade
entre gangsters et convoyeurs de fonds
les gangsters c'était en bus qui est
dans une camionnette garée à proximité
d'une entrée de service de lagence
haussmann de la banque verte
ils ont pu s'enfuir avec un butin de
près d'un million de francs deux
employés de banque ont été blessé ainsi
que l'un des gangsters et un passant
à berlin est une cérémonie a été
organisée pour fêter la libération de
luis corvalan le leader du parti
communiste chilien est toujours à moscou
mais à ce jour personne ne l'a encore vu
quant au dissident soviétique vladimir
boukovski qui a été échangé contre
louise corbalan il réside actuellement
en suisse le mystère subsiste quant au
pays où il pourrait se fixer en tout
état de cause le président chilien le
général pinochet lui offert de
s'installer au chili
le métier d'arbitré parfois rude
regardez ces images elles ont été
tournées à hanovre en allemagne pendant
un combat d'amateurs il a suffi de la
maladresse d'un des boxeurs pour envoyer
larbitre au tapis
ans
sport toujours pour la troisième fois
alain gilles le capitaine de l'équipe de
basket de villeurbanne a donné à son
équipe et vous l'avez peut-être vu hier
dans stade 2 le panier de la victoire
villeurbanne leader du championnat a
donc remporté grâce à lui une victoire à
l'extérieur une de plus mais de justesse
alain gilles depuis 17 ans qu'il joue en
division nationale est véritablement
devenu un phénomène du basket et cela
mérite je crois que nous vous le
présentions un peu mieux alain gilles
c'est devenu un joker dans le jeu de
biedermann champion d'automne de basket
le voici à l'oeuvre à la dernière
seconde de la rencontre c'est le numéro
4 des verts à ce moment-là son équipe
menait d'un point par berck hamas perdu
mais il réussit l'exploit de marquer in
extremis le panier de la victoire d'un
coup de patte il renverse le cours du
match
c'est donc la troisième fois cette
saison qu'il réussit ce tour de force
il a déjà battu nice et bagnolet de la
même façon des semaines précédentes
à 32 ans à l'âge il est encore le
meilleur et pour son entraîneur andré
buffière c'est un monument dans le
basket français
les all ages il se défend pourtant
d'être un phénomène
on ne sait pas un phénomène disant qu'il
faut un joueur pour marquer à un dernier
panier c'est tombé sur moi les deux
dernières fois bon parce que peut-être
le jeu est axé sur man en fin de partie
parce qu'il faut le un joueur qui
prennent des responsabilités puisque un
autre et là jusqu'à présent peut-être
c'est dans mon tempérament je sais pas
je les prends ça réussit ou c'est
réussit pas eu jusqu'à présent ça j'ai
eu pas mal de changer ce côté là mais
quand même dû faire nous axe est axée
sur sur moi parce que je sais pas
prouvée la raison ce stage vous êtes la
manette je pense pas non ya pas qu'un
joueur puisse marquer un peu plus qu'un
autre ça c'est certain mais une vedette
non à la gilles peut-être malgré lui qui
sera dimanche prochain l'invité de
l'émission stade 2 un résultat de ski
les autrichiennes toujours imbattable en
descente ainsi aujourd'hui dans la
descente de l âme z comptant pour la
coupe du monde bien sûr brigitte
totschnig est arrivée première avant
deux de ses compatriotes cannes
compatriotes par devant anne marie paul
nicholas boys si vous êtes passionné de
football nous avait sans doute déjà vu
avec un peu d'amertume ces images de
bagarres au cours du match nice bastia
samedi remportée par nice 5 à 0 sur son
terrain
les incidents sérieux éclatèrent après
le troisième but de nice un accrochage
entre deux joueurs toko et casey ce fut
le détonateur d'une bagarre générale
tout le monde alors un peu perdu la tête
y compris dans les tribunes du public et
bord du terrain ou entraîneurs
dirigeants et remplaçants des deux
équipes
ces invectives air copieusement à coup
sûr samedi à nice le sport n'a pas gagné
grand chose de ce pitoyable spectacle
autrefois
vous vous en souvenez il existait en
cours de championnat une journée de
derby c'était la journée me rappelait
tout à l'heure vers shabbat la journée
de véritable fête régionale
aujourd'hui c'est tournoi deux voisins
sont venus pas pour tous mais presque
des querelles de palier mais aucune il
est vrai n'a atteint l'intensité et la
régularité surtout des batailles rangées
auquel participeront yeuse mans
maintenant niçois et bastié le tout dans
un climat de haine que le moindre
incident et surtout le moindre crétins
fait exploser à vrai dire en faisant
compte on peut d'abord se demander quels
sont donc ces professionnels entre
guillemets du football
incapable de sang froid et de maîtrise
entraîné par et il a un métier de sport
qui comporte en premier lieu le respect
des règles à défaut de celui
l'adversaire que sont aussi finalement
ses dirigeants dont l'affluence ne
freine rien et ses arbitres dont
l'autorité n'effraie personne on peut se
demander encore si le sport en la
matière n'est pas le reflet de la
politique au fond punir les supporters
de bastia
ne risque-t-on pas des incidents graves
incidents qui ramasserait tous les
mécontentements de lille tous les échos
d'attentes
en réalité je sais que les corses se
sentent mal aimés
j'ai l'impression aussi que marseille et
surtout nice ont pour eux l'odeur de
l'ennemi réitère c'est à dire le
continent paris le pouvoir lointain est
indifférent c'est à dire aussi le mépris
l'abandon d'une terre que ses hommes au
point un vif m
jusqu'au fond des tripes cela mais cela
seul on peut le comprendre
à l'heure des vacances scolaires et des
départs pour noël peut-être en êtes vous
encore à vous interroger sur le choix de
votre moyen de transport la route pas
très sûr en hiver le train assurément
bondée où l'avion et ses petites
compagnies qui vous emmène pratiquement
de la porte de votre maison à celle de
votre destination bord de mer ou pistes
de ski sont bien pratiques
depuis quelques années aral père alsace
et r'way retour nerfs transport et bien
d'autres sillonnent la france dans tous
les sens qui sent dans le ciel de
l'hexagone un réseau comme vous le
constatez un réseau de plus en plus
serrés l'inconvénient est l'état il sait
que pour bon nombre de ces compagnies
les lignes qu'elle assure ne sont pas
rentables trop de frais trop de
passagers à sa pleine saison mais
surtout trop peu de passagers le reste
du temps cette année les compagnies
d'aviation régionale auront transporté
près de 600000 passage ce résultat est
d'autant plus remarquable qu'il y a dix
ans ce type de transport n'existait
pratiquement pas en france aujourd'hui
60 villes c'est à dire toutes les villes
françaises de plus de 50000 habitants
sont desservies par avion grâce aux 19
compagnies régionales qui se partagent
le territoire un développement
spectaculaire de ce type de transport
donc mais un développement problématique
car cette année presque toute cette
compagnie notamment les deux plus
grandes tat air alpes ont des
difficultés financières
elles ont atteint un palier qu'il faudra
maintenir encore qu'il faudra maintenir
surtout pour les deux prochaines années
je crois que pour l'année 1977 ce sera
la consolisation du palier lui même sur
laquelle il faudra naviguer jusqu'à la
fin la décennie en cours
en fait l'aviation régionale a sans
doute grandit trop vite
les compagnies ont voulu couvrir tout le
territoire français quitte à créer des
lignes déficitaires
et puis certaines compagnies ont sans
doute vu trop grand en achetant des
appareils difficile à rentabiliser comme
ceux fokker à réaction dont deux
compagnies viennent de faire
l'acquisition
finalement ils ont toujours survécu
grâce aux subventions des collectivités
locales ou de l'état et subventions sur
certaines lignes
ce monde parfois 500 francs par passage
mais pour le gouvernement c'est une
situation qui ne doit pas dur
je crois qu'il est normal qu'au départ
une compagnie régionale et des
subventions pour démarrer comme
d'ailleurs à la uaar inter à ses débuts
mais il est aussi nécessaire que ces
subventions diminuent dans le temps car
il faut que ces compagnies arrivent à
avoir leur bilan d'exploitation
équilibré et si certaines compagnies
aujourd'hui en difficulté c'est
précisément parce que elle était partie
hypothèses trop optimiste qui ne
permettait pas d'avoir peint trafic
équilibré d'où leurs difficultés et ça
veut peut-être dire aussi moins de
subventions ça veut peut-être dire aussi
les suppressions de lignes il peut
arriver qu'il ya des suppressions de
lignes et ces jours-ci notamment une
ligne transversale a été supprimé il y
avait six passagers par jour et par
avion
parce que l'avion commercial est
exportable actuellement avec six
passagers
évidemment non le gouvernement donne
donc un coup d'arrêt cela avait commencé
avec le refus d'ouvrir cet été la ligne
paris avignon
dorénavant il y aura moins de
subventions alors pour survivre les
compagnies devront faire des efforts de
gestion et de diversification
surtout elles devront harmoniser leurs
politiques avec la compagnie nationale
air inter pour ne pas lui livrer une
concurrence inutile peut dire que nous
sommes en train de devenir le vrai
complémentaires terrain terre il ya eu
un petit passage qui était celui nous
avons le puberté et nous étions les
grands amis des rentes r et puis lorsque
l'âge de raison et venues on nous a
donné des ailes et qu'on nous a même
taillé en pointe et je crois que la
raison a pris rapidement le dessus car
il est clair que les grandes compagnies
dont des rentes et redevenait de parler
et vous l'avez entendu récemment ont
déclaré que l'aviation que nous avons
créé la version que nous avons développé
leur est nécessaire pour autant que nous
soyons des gens sérieux et que nous le
prouvent ion dans les années qui vont
venir entre la complémentarité les
problèmes financiers la marge de
manoeuvre est étroite
d'autant qu'il faut prendre en compte un
élément essentiel la réorganisation du
transport aérien
ne doit pas nuire au développement des
villes et des régions la météo pour
terminer demain le temps sera doux en
particulier le matin mais assez nuageux
du bordelais des landes aux alpes et aux
régions méditerranéennes il y aura
encore des vents assez forts dans le
midi toujours de la neige au dessus de
15 100 m il fera doux également bretagne
avec un ciel très nuageux et des pluies
ailleurs le temps sera frais surtout
dans l'est où l'on observera de faibles
gelées en particulier demain matin ainsi
que des brumes et des brouillards
givrants l'après-midi de rares
éclaircies pourront se développer avec
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce journal
bonsoir à tous et tout de suite le
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité
au liban les réfugiés commencent à
revenir
la crise gouvernementale pourrait
relancer la négociation avec les pays
arabes
claude couler est nommé secrétaire
d'état auprès de michel d'ornano
les communistes appliqueront l'accord
d'union pour les municipales le dernier
journal à 23h35